it gives me great pleasure
to introduce today's plenary session
hosted by dr carl june director of the
center of cellular immunotherapy's
pro-men school of medicine and the
director of the parker institute for
cancer immunotherapy at the university
of pennsylvania
today carl june will be sharing the
state of the art with carti therapy
and the title of his presentation is
interrogating the genotype
and phenotype of car t cells in the
tumor micro environment
well it gives me great pleasure to
participate in this advance in science
the first cobit-induced
virtual science program put on by nana
string and today i'm going to talk about
our results with
our car t cells and using the new
genomics platform to interrogate the
tumor microenvironment
my disclosures are here the relevant
ones are novartis
and community therapeutics
so about 20 years ago we began working
on
car t cells initially an hiv infection
and then later in
patients with various cancers
and um the cars became more and more
sophisticated over time
with the incorporation of co-stimulatory
domains
the initial car had only this data chain
of the t
cell receptor and that led to limited
proliferation of the car t cells when
they found antigen
but they did persist very well in fact
we have data that
they are still in patients more than 15
years
since their first infusion
however those first generation car cells
when they were tried in cancer did not
work
in that they persisted for only a few
days
in the cancer patients probably related
to the more
toxic immune environments in cancer
patients than
they are in patients who have hiv and
who are on antiretroviral therapies
so the field then began to test car t
cells having more complex co-stimulatory
domains
uh with so-called hard wiring of the
co-stimulation such as cd 28 or 401 bb
into the car t cell
and those began uh
trials in 2010 and 11
and then became
[Music]
fda approved in 2017 with yes carter
having a cd-28 signaling domain
now marketed by gilead and uh
mariah having a 4bb sibling domain and
now marketed
by novartis for leukemia
and lymphoma
and so that began a new cell therapy
industry
in that this is very different than the
standard
pharmaceutical model where the drug
company will make
a small molecule and enlarge
lots and distribute it to many thousands
of patients
in this case the car t cells that are
initially fda approved are
in so-called nf1 cell products in that
they're autologous
and derived from the patient and then
manufactured and then crowd preserved
and fused into the patient so there are
many steps on this but the logistics
much more complex
certainly than standard
pharmaceutical approaches
and we're still in the midst of
this new industry in
making the cell therapy and
manufacturing more
automated and less labor complex but in
the case of leukemia there was no real
issue with studying
the car t cells in the patient because
they circulate in the patient
and also are easily found during
standard of care
bone marrow biopsies however with solid
tumors the car t
cells leave the blood and go into the
tumor micro environment and that's
what i'll be focusing on today
so there are basic differences between
these two commercially marketed
uh car t cells uh both in their vector
design from money ball vectors or
retroviral vectors
the promoters uh and they both have the
same binder to the ce-19 molecule that's
found on normal b
cells and leukemia cells or lymphoma
cells
they have different uh co-stimulatory
domains as i
pointed out a moment ago different hinge
and transmembrane domains and very
different persistence
in patients and we believe most of that
is
difference in persistence in patients is
due to
the differences in the co-stimulatory
domain cd28 compared to four and bb
my colleagues david porter and
yost horse and joe fryetta have studied
now the first two patients we treated
in in this paper published in 2018 they
showed that the car t
cells have survived for more than five
years
in both patients and we think these are
actually not the initial
cells infused into the patient but the
progeny
or daughter cells of those who divided
in the patient and yet continue to carry
the transgene to the car because they
have
an integration uh generally one or two
copies of the car
per um t cell so this really is what's
transformational for the pharmaceutical
industry it's the demonstration that you
can
create a living drug that will persist
in patients
for years and we we showed in that work
that we could re-isolate the cells
from patients and that they would then
um
still be able to kill leukemia cells in
a c19 specific manner so they
remain on imminent surveillance even
after the patient has been
induced into remission
and we studied both in acute leukemia
patients
and chronic lymphocytic leukemia
patients these
uh the long-term surviving patients and
the car t cells that we could re-isolate
from their blood and in this slide in
panel a
is on the left is a demonstration
of the car survival measuring both
[Music]
by a pcr acid
the number of copies of the car t
cell transgender in blood on a log scale
and
you can see there's a about a two log
difference in a patient who had a
complete response
compared to those who have non uh
response or nr
and and below that on the left is a plot
of the
normal and malignant b cells in the
patient
and you can see that the patients with
complete remission
have the levels of b cells
become undetectable below the limit of
detection in the assays whereas the
non-responding and partial responding
patients
have either no response or a partial
response
so this is our first clue that the
proliferation of the car t cells in
patients
is associated with responses and we've
since found that
in many other kinds of cancer beyond cll
for instance
for instance in lymphomas
and in patients with myeloma
so on panel b on the right we studied
some of these
long-term t cells and in this case
cells in the infusion product uh
in in the patient and what we find is
that there's a
very large difference in for instance in
uh the amount of memory cells in the in
the infused product
and that's higher in the patients with
cr
or complete remission than in the
partially or non-responding patients
conversely in the lower right in panel g
we find that
they're um if you measure
genes signatures associated with t cell
exhaustion that
those are very low in the infused
product in
responding patients and exhaustion is
easily detectable
in the non-responding uh cohort
so the quality of the infused cells is
important
in determining the later response
of the patient
we uh continued our initial studies in
acute leukemia
and had as a swimmer plot shows that
the patients with complete responses
there was an extraordinarily high
complete response rate in patients with
relapsing refractory
leukemia with over 90 percent of the
patients
in remission within a month after
treatment so
in a phase one trial of refractory and
relapse patients this is
the highest response rate that had ever
been recorded
these data and others then replicated
at novartis led to fda approval in
august
of 2007 for pediatric and young adult
leukemia ages
3 to 25. so this was the first
time that a cell and gene therapy had
been and had reached
commercial approval in the united states
by the food and drug administration but
what i'll do now is turn
to car t cell therapy for solid tumors
and um the elephant
in the room for that is it really that
many trials are underway for in patients
with solid tumors but as of yet
there have been no spectacular responses
as many groups have now seen for
hemologic
or blood cancers so there are many
reasons probably why solid tumors
uh are harder to treat with engineered t
cells and those could go from
trafficking
into the solid tumor to the more toxic
tumor micro environment and so the
central challenge to the entire field of
cell
therapy now is to identify those
barriers
so that they can be engineered around
in order to improve the efficacy of car
t cells
in patients with solid tumors and in the
next several slides i'll
focus initially with our car t cell
trials
targeting mesophylline and pancreatic
and ovarian cancer
and then at the end turn to
prostate cancer as a model of a solid
tumor
treated with engineered cells so
there are many reasons as potentially
as to why the efficacy is diminished
with solid tumor therapy compared to
a bone marrow derived malignancies this
cartoon shows that there are intrinsic
cell
qualities that that may change in the
solid tumor panel
on the patients on the left
that the tumor is more likely
to have the t cells be have poor quality
in the patient
even when they're taken out of the
patient for manufacturing
so we have recent and unpublished
studies in pancreatic cancer showing
that
the phenotype of circulating cells when
one looks at naive cells and effector
memory
and and central memory cells with with
high dimensional
uh time of flight sci-top
low cytometry that that they're they're
perturbed
in untreated patients with pancreatic
cancer compared to age-matched
controls so that that is
one area on the right panel is a cartoon
depicting the tumor microenvironment in
a solid tumor and there are many
barriers there from
uh collagen that may be limiting
access by diffusion and
cell trafficking into the tumor to um
many more suppressive cells since such
as
tumor derived t-regs
or myeloid-derived suppressor cells and
tumor-associated
macrophages so these all contribute to a
more
complex and toxic tumor microenvironment
and include also the metabolic
perturbations such as acidosis
and hypoxia in many solid tumor
microenvironments
so we've been working with nanostring
now for almost two years
trying to understand how we could study
these
complexities in the tumor
microenvironments with
car t cells and um we first began
to test in mouse models
with nsg mice that are xenografted
with um uh
human car t cells and and then
we then have moved more recently now to
studying patients
on our mesothelion trials with
pancreatic and ovarian cancer
and then our just beginning studies
in in the trial of prostate cancer
pancreatic cancer is one of the
worst cancers as far as prognosis
because at the time of diagnosis it is
usually
unresectable one one target in
pancreatic cancer that a car t
cell could access is mesothelion this is
a gpi linked
protein that's overexpressed on more
than 90
of pancreatic cancer cells as well as
some other solid tumors such as
ovarian cancer and mesothelioma
so we have made several car t cells now
specific for mesothelion over the past
about 15 years the first one we did in
collaboration
with ira paston at the national cancer
institute
and he had made an antibody called ss1
uh that bound to the n-terminus of
mesothelion later in collaboration with
novartis we made a car against
a more membrane proximal epitope and
this car
is derived from human
antibody sequences as compared to the
ss1 that i mentioned which is
uh derived from a mouse hybridoma
as you can see on the top left panel on
biacore analysis
there is uh quite a large difference in
the kd or dissociation constant
of the ss1 binding to
immobilized mesothelioma compared to the
m5 so the
m5 car has about a 30-fold lower
affinity
and kd for mesothelion then
ss1 in addition as shown on the bottom
left um the
mapping of the epitope show that the ss1
car binds to the
end term mesmes of mesothelioma and the
uh and that the m5-carb rhymes to a
membrane proximal
epitope we then made these in the same
format
uh with car construction as with
raya so that they have a cd28 i mean a
41 bb
signaling domain as well as um a zeta
chain
expressed in t cells using a lentival
vector so very similar to how we do
the manufacturing and leukemia that's
just swapping out
the car design so we now
have done a series of clinical trials
phase one and pilot trials testing
uh these cars in patients with
pancreatic cancer and ovarian and
mesothelioma so
the initial trials we're testing ss1
and and these studies are published i'll
briefly summarize them
and we have ongoing trials with the m5
human based antibody car
that are open now for both mesothelioma
ovarian and lung cancer and you can find
details
about these trials with their nct
numbers at clinicaltrials.gov
and this paper published in 2018
summarized
our second trial in metastatic
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
or pda and we had six patients
in that trial and then panel c on the
left
the the patient was measured
uh at baseline and then after a month
after treatment
and the pet scanning with fdg
pet is used to assess tumor activity
and one out of the six patients had a
partial response as you can see
patient one one three in the green bar
that
goes down the other patients had either
stable disease or progressive disease
and panel e in the center is shown that
patient 113
with on pet scanning at baseline are
very active
and multiple metastatic lesions in the
liver
and in a month after treatment those
those are no longer
pet avid um and as which is also seen
in the unenhanced ct images and the pet
ct combined images shown in panel f
on the right and the bottom so that the
patient's
disease
regressed after a single infusion of
these car t cells
and the next slide here
shows that there's some evidence for
metastatic
for epitope spreading
and on the top on panel b in these six
patients
we plotted cytokines in the patients and
show that um
for five out of the six patients the
cytokines in the serum didn't change
um in the 30 days after infusion whereas
patient 113 who experienced an
anti-tumor response
is only one who had elevations and
cytokines particularly il-6
il-1 and il-18 we have also seen with
our ce19 cars that elevations and
cytokines
such as these shown here correlate with
response
um in in the patients um
[Music]
we found uh that uh the patients made
new antibodies against neo
antigens using the proto-array
in panel c so this was some evidence
that
um there had been
new moral responses made in the patients
against a variety of recombinant
proteins
and panel d has shown that the car t
cell is actually
infiltrated metastatic lesions that
could be
tested at biopsy time
biopsies post infusion
so those trials enabled us then to
move to testing the fully human car
called m5 and data didn't show you the
car t
cells did not persist long in that ss1
car trial that i just reviewed and what
we found was was that the
patients made immune responses against
the car molecule probably because it was
derived from
mouse hybridoma and is immunogenic in
humans
so now we're testing this m5 car that
has
a lower affinity and also
uh is fully human it turns out it's much
more potent
in two different cancer models on the
left in studies done novartis that
tested
infusions of the m5 car or
infusions of the ss1 mouse based car
against a xenograft in immunodeficient
mice
and only the m5 car was able to cure
those mice
and data out to 63 days after
implantation of the tumor and on the
right is
a series of pancreatic
pdx models so these are pancreatic
cancers
from single patients implanted in the
mice
and on the black is
controlled t cells for allergenic or
xenogenetic effects in these mice
and cart 19 was given as a control
uh since it targets c19 which is not
present on
pancreatic cancer and then the m5 car
and as you can see almost all the mice
treated with an
m5 car had tumor regression uh
in this very uh rigorous model so
in a head-to-head comparison the m5 card
is more potent
uh in our pre-clinical studies than the
um ss1 car
and that trial is is underway now
in two different trials with that m5 car
and so we have pancreatic tumor
biopsy specimens from from those
patients as well as a variety of other
samples such as
ascites and so on now to study the
activity of the car and then how the
tumor might respond to the car
targeting so uh there
but what i showed you is there are some
responses but they're
you know no one has had a complete
remission to date
with the car t cells uh against
pancreatic cancer that we have tested
and this is where now we are working
with manistering to
to interrogate the tumor
microenvironment and ask why we see
some responses in some patients and no
responses in others
so the geomics digital spatial profile
uh profiler is a is an instrument that's
uh quite complex but basically takes an
ffpe
specimen from a biopsy specimen of a
mouse or a human tumor specimen
then regions of interest or roi are
selected using the computer and a
microscope-based
approach to examine and detail the
protein
and rna content of those regions of
interest
then the antibodies and rna
hybridizations
are cleaved off with uv light
so that they can then be with a
microcapillary tip
aspirated off and then analyze
for the protein counter counting
which would be the same as ihc and then
also
rna to get an idea of the
transcriptomics of the tumor
tumor microenvironment and the car cells
so there initially uh the samples i'll
show you
have been run through the manuscript
encounter
to get the readout and there are many
different codes within each transcript
so that
only those that have all exon tags as
identified are registered as a true
signal
later uh mana string will come out with
a
ngs or next generation sequencing
approach
using for instance an aluminum platform
as well as the end counter readout they
expect this
a more broad application to be probably
come out i think in the third quarter of
uh
next of this year although that may be
in flux given
uh coved uncertainties
so we first began to analyze
uh samples of mice with human
tumor xenografts treated with human t
cells
and this is work with a graduate student
in my lab song the artwall and a
post-doc
maria asnar gomez and um
so the basic design of these experiments
is that immune deficient and nsg mice
were
injected either with an ovarian cancer
line called s
kob3 that has a lot of over expression
of
the her2 target and
in addition the pancreatic cancer line s
aspc-1
and then the mice were treated with
either a herceptin-based car
or with an anti-mesothelion car or utd
t-cells which is untransduced t-cells
and then
the tumors were at the most
mice were sacrificed tumors were
removed and then processed through ffpe
and
analyzed by the dsp system
on the right panel shows that the sklv3
tumors do completely regress
in mice uh treated with in this example
an anti-mesothelion car t cell
and so we've used that model as as as a
way to judge resistance mechanisms and
how to
improve car t-cell designs
so our first experiment then was to test
uh in the explanated tumor models
what um and identify regions of interest
roi so one of the most important aspects
that we found with this application of
geomix dsp technology to core t cells is
to really
understand how and where to set the
regions of interest
depends on what your question is for
instance do you want to know if the
tumor still expresses
the target in this case herceptin or the
herceptin target her too
are car t cells present in the tumor
et cetera so um in this tumor uh
experiment uh we were able to
use three different codes colors really
to understand
uh whether t cells were present using
cd3 staining and blue
her2 the tumor surrogate antigen which
is in red
and dna staining which is in blue
and and you can see in some of these
regions of interest that there are
some are almost devoid of t cells um
and others have concentrations such as
an roi too
um there are areas of naming car t
cells and others less and then there are
also tumors that are bright for her2
and others that are less however what we
realized in this experiment was we were
unable to discriminate between car t
cells in bystander t cells this is a
huge potential advantage of this
technology to understand the infused t
cells in their state compared to
cells that may have already been in
infiltrating the tumor the so-called
till that
are not necessarily antigen specific and
certainly don't have
the car molecule
so to do that we have combined rna scope
technology with the geomics dsp
platform and so this is a collaboration
between acd and dentistry
and this approach now the pipeline's
modified
in that we first identify where the car
t
cells are by using rna scope and in-situ
hybridization to identify
uh a sequence in the car molecule in
this case it's in the three prime
untranslated region then once we know
where car t cells are we can design
in the regions of interest to find areas
that are hot and certain in that they
have
a lot of car t cells in the area or
others that are devoid of t
cells than others that are tumor rich or
tumor
poor so the downstream processing is
similar to the standard
geometric dsp platform it's it's the
combination up front of rna scope
that allows us now to understand the
difference between a cd3 positive
t cell which could be a bystander t cell
or a
transgenic car t cell
and so that would stain with cd3 in both
cases
versus the car t cell they will only be
bound and show
uh rna scope hybridization
through uh the hybrid for the
three prime untranslated region of the
car molecule
so this has proved to be quite exciting
in this slide um on the right panel
is a xenograft tumor that was
excised from a mouse uh this is the ace
uh the aspc-1 pancreatic model and the
mouse
was treated with human t-cells
expressing an anti
the anti the cm5 anti-mesothelion car
and as you can see some areas are
deep uh just green and have no other
markers so those are basically pure
tumor regions
other regions are are the pink and
uh yellow uh and um in some cases
they're merged together
those so those are t cells or c three
positive
um so you can see that there are t cell
rich areas in this tumor and others that
are t
cell to void and
on the upper on the left side on the
upper left of the four panels you can
see some cells that are clearly yellow
and others that are pink and others that
are green
so they're in this case three different
markers used
to to inform where to select our
regions of interest
so the next question then became and
this is what
size should our region of interest be
now we begin with rois of there were
circles 200 microns
in diameter and you can see in this
tumor
set of that there were rois identified
on the upper left they're uh
most some are completely green some have
many
uh yellow areas in there and
uh pink areas where they're
[Music]
very highly enriched for car t cells and
then others on the lower right where
there's
lots of tumor and also t cells
and a cd3 staining so
this that was then subjected
uh to uh various analyses
and these are the results uh
with the rois that we showed before
set at 200 microns
and what you can see here on the top
left are is the genes
uh canonical gene cd3 epsilon and this
these samples then were processed using
either a manual
processing before loading into the
geomics
instrument or using the lys leica
tissue processor that's automatic and
you can see there's a very high
correlation in the t cell genes
uh cd3 the wpre car gene
as well as on the lower left the
mesonelin
gene uh which is in the tumor cells in
those
images
and on this slide uh is the
[Music]
the rna results from that experiment
looking at the rna
so this is an 84 plex and we were able
to custom spike in
some extra genes to the standard package
of 84
probes and what one of the ones we
spiked in
was the wpre gene which is as i
mentioned
three prime uh untranslated region
in the car uh construct and
and here uh the rois are segmented out
into
car t cells only and car t cells mixed
in with tumor
and finally at the bottom on the right
you can see tumor
only and um
it's quite interesting now that we can
identify
a car t cell and separate that from the
rest so you can see in the tumor-only
area
uh many genes that are um
in the center that are blue on the
bottom tumor only
are genes that are t cell genes and the
arrows highlight
uh cd3 epsilon and you can see car t
cells only on the top
are bright red on the heat scale and um
uh
similarly wpre so we have now
specifically identified car t cells
in an ffpe embedded flank
tumor specimen from a mouse that had a
pancreatic tumor xenograft
so this has been a goal for a long time
now to be able to look at the genetics
both you know the transcriptional level
and by ihc
of cells interacting with the tumor
microenvironment
and um this first example here
uh you know mousinograph looks very
uh promising
so other than choosing where to set the
size
uh i mean the location of the roi as we
discussed previously in this experiment
we asked
what the size of the roi could be
um you know could we uh
decrease it from 200 microns down to
nearly single cell
resolution at 10 microns and so what
we've done here is
set rois along that as you can see on
the right from 200 to 10
and then looked at the number of rna
probes that were detected
and you can see that it's quite stable
plateaued down to about
an roi of 50 and then after that
they're quite the sensitivity falls off
so
so it looks like certainly using an rli
of 100 at the current level of
detection of these probes will be um
should be quite sensitive for detecting
transcripts
uh in in those fields
so next like to turn to where we're
going to go next with this
project which is to analyze the clinical
trial specimens from a trial we have in
prostate cancer and these
this is a car t cell that targets psma
the
prostate specific membrane antigen that
carries on as an extracellular
ectoenzyme involved in metabolizing
glutamate in folate and then psma has
been
known to be on prostate adenocarcinoma
and also to go up across various ethnic
groups with
tumors of advancing tumor grade
and stage
um and um in this car we've made
it's so-called an armored car in that
we've
uh put in a dominant negative receptor
to tjf beta
and the rationale for that is that tgf
beta is secreted
by prostate cancer cells and promotes
the growth
and establishment of the tumor stroma
and as well
has a very potent immunosuppressive
assay on t
cells that's been well characterized
over the years
so chris kloss when he was in my lab
designed
the psma dominant negative tgf beta
armored car
and at the lenovo vector is shown on the
left it has
this the single chain fd
to a psma and then coupled with
a t2a system to the dominant negative
tgf beta
receptor and he tested that in mouse
models
and showed that it was efficacious and
most strikingly
and not something we actually expected
to find was
he did a stress test with a prostate
cancer line called pc3 that has
that expresses the carb target psma
and on the lower right you can see that
um the growth of the
car t cells in the culture when
irradiated cancer cells were added at
weekly intervals to the culture
and if the car t cells have the dominant
negative
receptor they proliferated um and they
proliferated for about three weeks
longer than
if they just had the car alone which is
in green and denoted by
uh p b b z um
so that the dominant negative receptor
both uh
makes them insensitive to tgf beta and
uh
and what we showed in this paper is
makes them uh resistant
uh to exhaustion which uh at this point
the field thinks is a major issue with
the efficacy and holding back that
efficacy of car
t-cells so we were able to take those
pre-clinical studies and begin a
clinical trial at phase one trial led by
naomi haast and divik narayan
the trial design is shown here um
where the first two cohorts receive car
t cells
and then uh without any lymph depleting
and then the third cohort has mild lymph
depletion with a toxin
and this trial is open at the university
of pennsylvania and now at several other
centers around the country
and um what we found is in the those
initial two cohorts
was that the car t cells engrafted and
proliferated
as shown on the right with the same peak
the time to peak kinetics or the c-max
as we've seen in our leukemia patients
but here they're about two logs lower
in number if you look at the car copies
per microgram of genomic dna it's around
fp and two out of these three patients
are two thousand to three thousand
copies
uh per microgram of genomic dna and so
that's
about two logs less than what we've seen
um
in our leukemia studies but we're
excited by the first patient to go in
cohort three
who's shown here so this patient got the
same dose
of uh one to three times ten to the
eighth cars per meter square but in
addition
had the dose of satoxin given
the week prior to car t cell infusion
and uh shown on this
uh graph which is not linear
is that there is an exponential increase
in psa
in this patient on the previous
therapies he had
had that were failing and then the car t
cells were infused on day zero
and you can see that there was a very
rapid drop to zero within
three weeks after infused neurocartic
cells
a psa became undetectable he then had a
grade four or three
grade four cytokine release syndrome and
macrophage activation syndrome that
we've seen in our leukemia patients that
are responding
with uh very high levels of ferritin as
you can see on the
in the green flood so he had cytokine
release syndrome as toxicity
and an anti-tumor effect measured both
on circulating tumor cells
and um psa
so this protocol looks promising
but of course there is toxicity and i
think the best way to understand
what's happening is to analyze tissue
biopsies
um and apply those to the geometry
uh dsp platform and uh
joe fryetta and naomi naomi haas are
working with
manistering to do this and then to
interrogate these samples using the
cancer transcriptome atlas
that nanostring has put together where
there's about 2 000
their pathways can be profiled in biopsy
specimens so our approach here is
is to test the baseline biopsy
and then one that is obtained about 10
days after the patient's treated
and then so looking at the tumor and
baseline and then
after car treatment to examine for
instance whether or not the psna
expression has been modulated
in any way in addition we want to
compare the transcriptomic state of the
car t
cells in the biopsy specimen to the
infusion product
that we retained before from the
infusion
on day zero so for that we're gonna have
to do a cross platform
set of experiments to learn how to
compare the
the nanostring and encounter results
uh from the infused cells to what we get
on the um geomax dsp
platform so this is a
project underway and we don't yet have
results to show
so i'll just finish with two slides
showing where
where we're also going to imply that
which is we've
recently published in science the
results of using multiplex human genome
engineering
using crispr cast 9 to remove negative
checkpoints
in t cells of the pd1
gene as well as the t cell receptor
alpha and beta genes and
and insert a transgenic t cell receptor
and the results of those studies were
published in february and
you know a summary of those three
patients showed that it was safe
we had no off-target effects that were
unanticipated
the best response was stable disease in
two out of three patients
um and we had persistence of these gene
modified
t cells and gene edited cells shown on
the right in
patient 07 was that at about 30 days
after infusion
about 10 percent of those cells had uh t
cell receptor
disruption as well as pd1 disruption
so when we showed the single cell
analyses that in fact this was at the
level of the single human genome we were
able to
obtain editing of up to three genes at
one time
so our long-term goal then
would be able to apply the this dsp
platform
uh to those kinds of experiments where
we've used genetic modification of the
cells
as well as uh genetic editing um
and genomics uh that
is going to be improved for that because
mastering is working on incorporating
uh next generation sequencing to these
samples as as i mentioned earlier at
this point we're using encounter
uh but with next generation sequencing
we should be able to broaden out
what we do um and uh and incorporate
even
i think eventually some of the uses
endpoints are
modified cells that we've done using
crispr cast
9 technology and be able to quantify
gene edits
would be a long-term goal using this
technology
um so in addition to applying the cancer
transcriptome
atlas there's a number of other things
we'll be able to do
uh which when we get down to a single
cell level of
of um resolution um
in understanding the tumor
microenvironment and i think
you know one thing is that the
engineered t cells will have a real
advantage over checkpoints
analyzing resistance to checkpoint
therapies because
the engineered t cells can actually be
identified as we showed for instance
with a wpre analysis
in this kind of assay so we can
determine
whether it's a bystander cell or whether
it's the engineer t
cell we were hoping to test its
therapeutic
efficacy so i see a bright future ahead
in in applying this to our studies
and in summary just say that this the
um dsp technology now allows us to have
um high dimensional rna and protein
profiling
of tumor biopsies in our mouse
pre-clinical experiments as well as in
clinical trial specimens and the ongoing
uh
collaboration between the university of
pennsylvania and ministering
we've shown that this technology allows
us to
identify car t cells in the tumor
microenvironment
identify the tumor and
look at both levels of protein
expression
that are selected in as well as the
transcriptive
uh state of those t cells so in the long
run there will be i think a very
powerful technology to understand
uh the immune health of the cells that
we have infused and we want to
understand if they're
healthy effector cells memory cells or
are they tired and exhausted
t cells for instance which is
unfortunately what the tumor is very
good in inducing
now i'll conclude i would like to thank
all the people in my lab
uh joe fryetas on the extreme left
and who's the one who has done the work
that i showed recently in the prostate
cancer and also on the
crispr cas9 editing
paper that was in science and many
colleagues attend to thank
uh for this uh for these data
um and they're shown here at the center
for cellular immunotherapies
uh bruce levine and don siegel who've
done all the manufacturing in the cell
and vaccine and production facility
and the prostate cancer team and the
pancreatic m5 clinical team
and as well as our colleagues edna
string uh sarah church
uh isabel lee christina bailey and nero
ramachandran so i'd like to thank
you very much for your attention and
then i think we'll be able to take some
questions
it would help if i was unmuted thank you
carl june for that presentation
um you know we're on on behalf of our
partners acd carl
and then on behalf of nana string as
well we're thrilled to be working with
you especially be able to tease out
the the difference between bystander t
cells and engineered car t
cells and try to be able to tease out
the biology between that and the
interaction so i'm
thrilled to be working with you on this
we have a series of questions for you
um let me start by first just on the
disease type i know in a lot of the
presentations carl
you were talking about pancreatic and
maybe doing some work with prostate
cancer
in terms of as you enter into solid
tumors with car t
are there some solid tumors that you
think are more susceptible
to be treated by karki than others and
how do you think about which solid tumor
you go after first
so um that's a great question nero
um
when we look at tumors from
surgical biopsy specimens and test them
in in basically petri dish experiments
we find that
almost all cancer cells can be killed by
t cells
if we have a car target that we
uh do uh and tests so that um
uh if if the car t cells can get there
in a sufficient number
and overcome resistance mechanisms and
so on i think
all cancer cells can can be
targeted in principle so that there are
many issues such as fibrous capsules
around some tumors that prevent ingress
of cells
so then another strategy might be needed
there are many
checkpoints that differ between
different tumors that's an emerging
principle that
uh some tumors rely mainly on defense by
for instance a lot of regulatory t cells
other tumors use myeloid cells such as
myelodrive suppressor cells or
alternatively activated macrophages
to prevent the t cells from doing their
job so
um you know this is a very active area
of research now
um and i think um you know no one
suspected five years ago
that lung cancer you know which
no one thought that was an immunogenic
tumor that now the from there
for lung cancer is immunotherapy
really true now the question uh from the
audience is around pancreatic cancer and
why the prognosis for pancreatic cancer
is especially so bad
well you know that's a really good
question um
you know pancreatic cancer is almost
always uh has a mutation in
the k-ras gene which makes that
active and um one aspect
is that pancreatic cancer really is not
detected early you know
so that it's possible that if we had a
test like a pap smear for cervical
cancer that
early detection would change this
problem with pancreatic cancer where as
i mentioned now
it's usually only detected when it's too
late so early detection would matter
and then pancreatic cancer has
its own special immune defenses uh one
of those
is that um
there are t cells actually in a
pancreatic cancer
so it's very different than for instance
lung cancer where
times of surgery you find many t cells
already in the tumor specimen and
there's an ongoing
attempt by the immune system the tumor
in pancreatic cancer it's like the
immune system basically doesn't even
know it's there
that's called immune ignorance and in
immunology terms
interesting okay then um carl i know
um you talked a little bit about how
you're thinking about using dsp and you
showed
one of the data pieces on going down a
region of interest size
small features can you maybe comment a
little bit about the
how the technology might achieve you
know single cell resolution and what the
turnover time of the assay might be
yeah that's a it's a great question um
i mean getting down to single cell
resolution would be
an amazing uh advance um
and uh i mean already right now it's
it's such a uh
you know the ability to discriminate
cells that you've engineered
from the passenger cells that are
already there is going to be a big
advance
and um so i think um you know
at this point the turnover time uh
is uh you know when you have experience
you can do eight to 16 slides
in a day and a half and a half days um
this is much better than say
mass cytometry based acid
clinical trials and then i know most of
your
experiments have been with tissue
samples i'm curious about like bone
marrow samples and things like that
would you ask
first using the sample type but also
would you ask different questions
in those sample types than you would do
in sort of a solid tumor tissue
oh yeah there's a you know bone marrow
um
so there are a couple issues you know we
have either aspirates
and biopsies and you know in general
when they process a bone marrow biopsy
they decalcify it
uh and uh for the bone spicules and that
that then can
uh make technical problems with uh
immunoassassin
um so i i i from what i'm understanding
it's going to be possible
to do bone marrow specimens uh and um
i think this will be a huge advance we
we don't really
understand why in leukemia for instance
there are two main leukemias ones
you know the lymphoid leukemia uh
and um the immune response is very
different than it is
in myeloma leukemia and and uh so there
and it seems like their stem cell niche
is different and so
this technology i think is going to be
very useful to
uncover the basic immunobiology of
of stem cells and and then their
leukemia counterparts
got it and uh carl one last question
actually the the whole
use of crispr cast iron is an
interesting twist and that
capability have in terms of how you
might be able to modulate tissue samples
can you maybe elaborate on how crispr is
going to be adopted going forward into
carti therapy in terms of
how people started using crispr going
forward
yeah so you know this is one of these
great lessons of basic science and how
disparate fields can come together um i
i
think when uh you know genomic
editing tools first evolved
um i mean people are looking at
correcting in vivo gene defects such as
you know for instance thalassemia
and so on and um and it's turned out now
that
um with crispr it is so uh flexible that
multiple genes can be targeted at one
time so
literally um it's uh the
possibilities are are are really amazing
to ability to
improve immune cells so that they're
resistant to the normal
uh issues that a tumor will do to turn
them off
um so i think that so that's one
possibility which is it will extend
activity in solid tumors
the other is this emerging in you know
whole new field of
making other cells that aren't from the
patient be car t cells so using for
instance cord blood cells
that are normally thrown away when a
baby's born crispr
can make those cells now to be used in
other
individuals by engineering out molecules
such as a t cell receptor
so we're going to see many applications
of uh genome engineering to cell therapy
got it called there's a question here
around what's the risk of having
over-activation cytokine storms with
knockouts of inhibitory receptors via
gene editing
yeah well that's a really good question
um
uh and you know when you turn off
the immune system checkpoints um
the the main uh um
risk is going to be autoimmune disease
um and
so uh and you know we need more time to
understand how often that will happen we
do know with checkpoint therapy when
antibodies are given to block
checkpoints about 20 of people have
autoimmune side effects the most common
uh being thyroid
dysfunction hypothyroidism that can
occur uh
in addition to colitis so far with t
cell therapies
that have been car t cells this the
incidence has been lower
um and but cytokine storm could happen
if um uh you know
a many t cells c antigen at one time so
and those really at this point are hard
to predict
um in animal models this is one area
where a human
clinical trial is best uh to figure out
safety in these kinds of uh
settings well carl
i know we're up on the top of the hour i
want to thank you so much for the
content and taking questions this
morning
and to all the audience thank you for
attending and i hope you enjoyed that
thank you very much nero it's been a my
pleasure
thanks so much carl stay safe and enjoy
the rest of the day
you too bye-bye